[Music]
whose ball I had all friends he does
conceptual photographs actually they're
quite edgy
in a stay for a night in the bedroom
next to mine you rented those who hasn't
figured out yet that you have to ask
girls permission before you take your
photo
are you finding any inspiration around
here all finds inspiration everywhere we
realize that's your daughter sitting
there with your old flame I just don't
know what ideas are real and which are
[ __ ] I don't worry about real life
find something that excites you so I
guess that it's sex and violence that
excites you you got a bit no so have a
drink will you
hey what happened last night
how are you actually Nepal despite our
past he's still a stranger something
wrong there it's my take on John rivet a
lien horror films this is Hannah that I
lost project two
it feels real it is real cool at this
time I can't help feeling that he enjoys
violence especially against women we
still have rules are what sorts of
relationships are acceptable of course
we have rules maybe you just don't
almost like to fight them
[Music]
beeping
you say the same thing about you
are you afraid of me she's out there if
you're gonna show something you have to
really put yourself in the situation
imagine what it'd be like to actually do
it above million IMS
you